à partir de demain pendant trois jours
ce sera la deuxième édition de lire en
fête une opération destinée à encourager
la lecture le goût pour les livres avec
des festivals des rencontres des
ateliers d'écriture et de très nombreux
salons du livre c'est aussi l'occasion
de raviver des émotions lointaine parce
que malheureusement tout le monde ne lit
pas et que l'image télévisée ou non a
tendance à mettre fin à la culture du
livre mais c'est pas encore pour
aujourd'hui
ainsi jean jacques dufour et frédéric
basket la saint briac sur mer près de
saint malo en ille et vilaine ont connu
quelques bonnes heures en suivant le
facteur saint briac ces deux mille âmes
est un facteur qui comme nous se
prénomme marcel c'est un hasard mais
c'est bon signe surtout quand on veut
parler bouquin avec les habitants à
l'est la tournée commence
première étape le salon mixte je trouve
que quand on a travaillé toute la
journée
le fait de pouvoir s'évader le sport un
petit peu avec de la lecture man show
que ça a aidé à s'endormir chauffeur du
bus un coup son salut professionnel
après la coiffeuse à la page
l'hôtelière collectionneuse ici on ne
lit pas on entasse
daniel votre mari vous voulez laisser à
paris où les jetez vous voulez le garder
vraiment je vais garder parce que
j'espère bien en très peu de temps 10
minutes par ci une heure par là me
mettre enfin et non seulement à les
ranger et enfin les lire pour la beauté
du récit
j'aurais aimé continuer en vous disant
que l'homme des lettres était amateur de
nouvelles malheureusement c'est
impossible
marcel n'aime pas l'elysée
moi je lis la presse locale de légende
ou de sport c'est tout bouquin non pas
vraiment d'où viennent les kurdes ont
cependant mon truc attention marcel
n'est pas une exception
selon les statistiques un quart de la
population n'ouvre pas un livre de
l'année ce n'est pas l'envié qui manque
il paraît que c'est le temps que le
temps sans même nom réalisé alors je dis
jamais et petit quand vous étiez qu'il
produit pas du tout chez clo qu'on a
tellement de temps d'hier facéties du
destin la bibliothèque est située juste
en face du bar de la mairie un endroit
pour voir à côté d'un endroit pour
dévorer décidément la vie de province a
vraiment des avantages puisque on vise
en général beaucoup de policiers surtout
et les policiers c'est le genre préféré
d'environ 30% des français
évidemment je cause des grands parce que
les enfants si on les laissait faire il
se gaverait essentiellement de bd lucky
luke spirou et dans certains cas le
petit féroce qu'est-ce qu'ils y arrivent
comme histoire conférences et puis ils
ont cherché des tigres à dents de sabre
et ça fait peur le tigre à dents de
sabre
non nous presser sans avoir un plan
széchenyi
commencé il y a trois heures la tournée
du préposé s'achève et allez savoir
pourquoi c'est à ce moment là que l'on
trouve la perle françois camionneurs
origines jouable mais l'iran pourquoi il
ya eu un déclic c'était marqué sur mon
bouquin que nous s'appelle larbaud
valery larbaud qui a des lectures c'est
un vice impuni
donc ça m'a plu un vice impuni qui
échappe malheureusement à plus de deux
millions de personnes
c'est en gros le nombre d'illettrés en
france